what's the most ridiculous what was the
most inappropriate Kids Bop song because
some of the songs you're like how did
they how did that make it to a Kidz Bop
compilation I think
um one of the ones that we perform well
okay we performed what's that Macklemore
song what are you talking about being in
the same level oh thrift shop that was
called Thrift Shop I'm like he's talking
about being in another Shop thrift shop
we did that one and it's like you know
there's a lot of like rapping in it so
we had to change a lot of words because
they were not appropriate for kids right
so that was interesting the things that
we changed it to were really funny and
then
um Locked Out of Heaven that was also
really
Bruno Mars yeah yeah Bruno Mars if you
listen his lyrics sometimes you're like
oh yeah it's almost like when you listen
to the weekend [__] like you really
listen and you're like
oh the weekend might have a drug problem
I love that though the weekend's my
favorite probably my favorite like I
mean I just love I don't know if I
listen to anyone more than the weekend
I love the weekend he's amazing did you
see him at a Sofi no but she did it was
[__] fire really I went the night
before he didn't perform because he
would you know he came out on stage and
like apologized to everybody because his
voice wasn't you know oh no which I
actually liked because most people would
have just pushed through but he was like
nah I gotta do this the right way
we're in LA but he's amazing damn wait
did he come in like he spin yeah he
redid it like a few I said I think it's
like a month and a half or two later and
then it's on HBO now I just watched it
tripping on shrooms oh good for you yeah
should I do that do you want to eat
rooms right now
um
I think Christine would have had his
advice again okay I just gotta ask um we
do have them we have the raw we have the
gummies you just let me know me and uh
Ray srimmer were Truman hard during our
interview really yes like things are
getting real realistic yes you enjoy uh
psilocybin I really enjoy it and I don't
do nothing I don't drink good I don't
smoke weed I don't do nothing but you'll
you'll partake in I just said nothing
but mushrooms shrooms are great they're
amazing yeah they're literally like
medicine I have people who uh like a
couple of my friends they'll microdose
before they work out because it gives
them like a little more focus a little
more energy and like a little lift yeah
and DMT no I want to try it I'm scared I
don't I don't think I would do it why
not because I'm bipolar as [__] it might
get rid of that I'm not well the
mushrooms do that for me I'm good I'm
good with that maybe one day or
Ayahuasca like Aaron Rodgers I do want
to do Ayahuasca though I actually do I
heard that'll change it that's like 30
years Chelsea Handler do it on her show
how was that it was so interesting like
she was like crying at the end and [__]
talking I have a friend who changed
their whole life her sister and like it
just changes everything I mean mushrooms
did that for me too the first time I how
much did you eat though did you eat a
lot well I we made it in tea oh so
that's so you it was good because it was
like I could just slowly get into it and
take more and more and I didn't know
what to expect that's how much I love
belly's like that belly only likes it in
tea he's like big shroom guy but he
drinks it I don't know if I could drink
it
there's like no escaping if you drink it
I feel like you actually can
well from what I was told but like if
you go to I went to Amsterdam
and they like it's so different there
because they it's like it's like yeah
it's just how it is it's like a
dispensary but it's like New York City
now different I've been in New York
recently you just go to the liquor store
like literally the corner store in New
York City they got shrooms right behind
the counter it's [__] in New York
City you could buy a blunt an eighth and
some mushrooms all at the bodega now
well we'll be there why it's the Wild
Wild West right now so you'll see just
anywhere where they got like a smoke
shop just walk in they right behind the
counter this is wow it's on display
that's good you got it yeah in Amsterdam
they said that I love it because they
like actually educate you right and [__]
and like they'll give you like a slip
and like tell you exactly how to do it
but they were saying if you start to
feel too high or you're like not feeling
good just drink juice as soon as you eat
something with like a high amount of
sugar in it it will start bringing down
your high I'd rather eat too much
shrooms than eat too much weed
because eating too much weed is terrible
it's the worst [__] ever you've ever had
like a like a bad edible experience the
worst I've never had that but I've I've
literally
I can't even do CBD that's how bad it is
well I don't think cbd's a thing I think
it's like you know one of those things
where like mentally you think it's
supposed to help you out but it's like
but it's a placebo effect it's like you
got a CBD massage my wife got a CBD
massage in Palm Springs this weekend so
what do you think that is
okay what the [__] are they gonna do
they're gonna rub CBD on you here's a
blunt smoke it
I mean yeah it's not good for me so you
get paranoid no I had like a full-on
episode like it was bad so you're out on
the 420 on the THC it's not for you no
that's good none of that I'll celebrate
with mushrooms shrooms are amazing